SET TO MEET WITH GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND TRY TO EXTRACT
INFORMATION FROM HIM.
HE HAS A NEW BOOK OUT, HOW I GOT
CAUGHT IN THE CROSS HAIRS TO
BRING DOWN A PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PROBABLY THE MOST ACCURATE TITLE
OF A BOOK AND A LONG TIME.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE YOUR EXPERIENCE
WITH THE WOMEN YOU BELIEVE WAS
SENT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
I RECEIVED AN UNSOLICITED EMAIL
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016 FROM A MAN
WHO WAS SUGGESTING THAT HE
WANTED TO PAY ME $3,000 TO WRITE
A REPORT ON ENERGY SECURITY
QUESTIONS AND I WAS A EXPERT ON
IT AT THE TIME AND ISRAEL,
TURKEY AND CYPRUS.
I LOOKED HIM UP BECAUSE I'D
NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
I SAW THAT HE HAD WORKED IN FOUR
ADMINISTRATIONS AND HE WAS A
PROFESSOR AT CAMBRIDGE SO
ACCEPTED HIS OFFER AND HE FLEW
ME TO LONDON WHERE HE PAID FOR
MY FIVE STAR HOTEL AND HE SAID
BEFORE I MEET WITH YOU I WANT
YOU TO MEET MY ASSISTANT.
HE PUT THIS ASSISTANT IN AN
EMAIL CHAIN ALONG WITH ME AND I
SAW HER NAME, I RECOGNIZED IT AS
TURKISH WHICH WAS SUSPICIOUS
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE MY POLICY
POSITIONS THROUGHOUT MY ENTIRE
CAREER ARE VERY HOSTILE TO
TURKEY.
WHEN I NOTICED A TURKISH NAME I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY SHE WOULD
BE INVOLVED.
I WENT AND I MET WITH HER AND
SHE WAS VERY SUGGESTIVE AS YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND, YOUNGER, VERY
FLIRTATIOUS.
I RIGHT AWAY UNDERSTOOD THIS
WASN'T A CAMBRIDGE ASSISTANT AND
SHE BARELY SPOKE ENGLISH AND SHE
WAS VERY FLIRTY AND WAS TRYING
TO DO TWO THINGS, WANT TO
EXTRACT INFORMATION ABOUT MY
PROFESSIONAL CONNECTIONS IN
THE MIDDLE EAST AND TWO TO SEE I
THE MIDDLE EAST AND TWO TO SEE F
HAD ANY INFORMATION THAT SHE
COULD POTENTIALLY EXTRACT FROM
MEAT ON A TRUMP RUSSIA WHICH IS
NONSENSE.
AFTER I MET WITH HER SHE THEN IS
INTRODUCED TO ME AGAIN THE NEXT
DAY WHERE SHE GOES FROM THIS
SUGGESTIVE YOUNG LADY WHO NOW
POURING HIS COFFEE AND STUFF ON
HIM IS VERY BELLIGERENT.
I EXPLAINED HOW BELLIGERENT HE
IS AND HE INVITED ME TO
CASTIGATE ME ABOUT MY POLICY
POSITIONS AND OF COURSE SHE THEN
TOOK ME TO DINNER AND WAS JUST
BASICALLY TRYING TO EXTRACT
INFORMATION.
I WAS VERY SUSPICIOUS.
FROM THAT MOMENT I KNEW THERE
WAS SOMETHING WRONG AND I WAS
LAUGHING ABOUT IT BUT NOW COURSE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THAT SHE WAS SOME SORT OF AGENT
BUT I DON'T THINK SHE WAS FBI, I
THINK SHE WAS CIA.
>> Tucker: SHE WAS DISPATCHED
BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
BARACK OBAMA WAS THE PRESIDENT
AND LEAD THE BRANCH INCLUDING
THE CIA AND FBI AND EVERY OTHER
AGENCY.
SPYING ON, THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY WHAT
HAPPENED AND I WANT TO MAKE
SOMETHING VERY CLEAR.
I DON'T THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS TWEETING ABOUT U.K.
INTERFERENCE FOR NO REASON LAST
WEEK, LET ME EXPLAIN WHY.
THE DAY I MET WITH THEM IN
LONDON I WAS INVITED BY THE
BRITISH MINISTRY OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS TO MEET WITH THEM AT
THEIR OFFICE IS CONCLUDING WITH
TOBIAS ELLWOOD WAS THE NUMBER
TWO AT THE TIME UNDER BORIS
JOHNSON SO CLEARLY WHEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SUGGESTED
THEIR REPORTING THAT THE BRITISH
WERE TOLD OF THIS OPERATION, I
BELIEVE THE BRITISH ACTIVELY
WORK SPYING ON ME AS WELL THAT I
BELIEVE PART OF WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TWEETING
LAST WEEK ABOUT THE PRINTER
SPYING WAS ABOUT THIS
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS OPERATION.
I GUESS WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO
FIND OUT.
>> Tucker: I WOULD REMIND OUR
VIEWERS, YOU ENDED UP GOING TO
JAIL BRIEFLY.
CORRECT?
>> I WENT FOR 11 NIGHTS.
>> Tucker: YOU GO TO JAIL AND
YOU DIDN'T SPY FOR RUSSIA OR DO
ANYTHING WRONG IN YOUR LIFE IS
DESTROYED, BUT WE SHOULD FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS HAPPENED BECAUSE,
WHY?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> WE DEFINITELY NEED FIND OUT.